avete presente quei video che ogni tanto
faccio perché sono incazzato per
qualcosa questa volta sono incazzato nel
mentre che devo fare un blog perché non
uniamo tutte e due le cose
allora rega bongiorno ciò che fai ma
butta gli accendini e cazzi e mazzi io
non fumo quindi non posso buttare a
cenni non bevo quindi non posso buttare
le bottiglie e allora che cazzo lancio
per essere incazzato sullo sfondo mi
spiego brevemente qual è il problema di
chiuderei devo detto che oggi avrei
fatto un fari rispondo vero avrei
risposto alle vostre domande più
frequenti nulla di queste una di queste
non era una domanda ma era più che altro
una considerazione favi ma sei un ladro
vi giuro che questa è stata una delle
domande più frequenti per un semplice
motivo che adesso vi spiego nei commenti
del canale ultimamente sta succedendo
una cosa che mi fa di un incazzare ci
sono delle persone su youtube
comunemente dette teste di ca ancor più
comunemente dette viscidi sacchi di
vanno sotto i canali degli youtubers più
seguiti quindi io quindi terni quindi
ipantellas si creano un canale con il
nome è l'avatar dello youtuber in
questione quindi nel mio caso si creano
un canale con scritto fa vj tv con il
mio avatar
e scrivono un bel messaggio sotto il
ministri vito impersonando c scrivendo
questa bellissima cosa
ciao ragazzi ho una grandissima sorpresa
per voi per sole due ore avrete la
possibilità di prendere un sacco di
gemme clash royale qui e poi incollano
un link dove scaricare appunto queste
gemme di cles royale dopodiché si
gustano di brutto e mi piace al commento
il problema è che quando una per un
ragazzino comunque una persona va a
cliccare su quel link che io non ho
assolutamente cliccato perché non ci
tengono anche a sapere che cazzo c'è
probabilmente ci sono ti fanno fare
degli account look sono dei virus non
sarà che cosa c'è dietro ma sicuro non
ci sono gemme di crash royale mai nella
vita è una puttanata bella e buona per
fare cliccare su quelli che in qualche
modo sti tizi ci guadagna
in questo modo non so come non lo voglio
sapere se noi li cancelliamo il commento
di blocchiamo dal canale in tempo due
minuti ritornano con un nuovo canale
perché ne avranno cratico cosa come un
miliardo quindi per noi è impossibile
rimuoverli perché ritornano subito
quindi bruttissima grandissima testa di
chi youtube se ne sbatte altamente le
palle però quando metti un video dove
che potrebbe contenere delle tette che
non ci sono porca [ __ ] allora li si ke
te lo bloccano
sette delle teste di minchia quando uno
di sti stronzi scrive una di queste cose
a rispondetegli sotto commentate
rispondi e scrivete sotto hashtag le
gemme infilatele su per il culo quindi
ovviamente la gente pensando che io
mettessi queste cose credono che io vada
rubare alla gente con con di virus
problema non sono io che metto
stackhouse e porca eva lercia detto
questo ragazzi passiamo al prossimo
punto si chiama un sacco di domande
arrivano anche da persone che magari
sono nuove iscritte non mi seguono da
tanto mi chiedevano ad esempio da dove
vengo insomma queste cose basilari
quindi faccio un recap completo per chi
non mi conoscesse per la 475 esima volta
ma non sarà l'ultima ciao mi chiamo
lorenzo ostuni non bevo da mai
vabbè l'altro settimana vabbè però poco
perché sono state 21 anni quasi ventidue
sono nato a torino vivo a milano perchè
sono bello e faccio le cose i video per
vivere questo sono io così ho risposto
tipo al 50 per cento delle domande
andiamo sull'altro 50 per cento la prima
arriva da uno dei video che è uscito
durante la settimana che è stato il
video che ho fatto con jacopo che questo
bambino che è apparso in un mio video
abbiamo fatto la prova non ridere
challenge valigie ma che jacopo per te
e mia moglie allora la domanda è lecita
perché potrebbe essere il mio fratello
come il mio cugino come mio suocero come
non lo so la risposta è che in realtà
non è nessuno di questi a livello di
parentela non è nessuno per me perché è
il nipote di lorenzo che è lui e suo
nipote lui non è imparentato con me non
ci assomigliamo manco pur gas ma sono
forse per il nome ed è suo nipote vi ho
conosciuto conosce ovviamente da un
botto di tempo non troppo perché fino
all'altro ieri manco era nato però vabbè
fari hai una passione oltre a youtube
in realtà si è una passione che
continuano a non troppi simo in realtà
però mi piace un sacco che è quella
della musica mi intriga un sacco invece
la musica e dm che è quella che fa tunz
tunz ed è per questo motivo che ho un
una console che odi l'annuncio vogliano
babele avente una console che ho pagato
la bellezza di 80 dollari perché sono
tirchio come la merda delle cuffie che
mi hanno regalato che ovviamente non ho
comprato io ho sempre perché sono
tirchio come la merda un lounge vad pro
che in teoria costa 200 e passa euro ma
non l'ho comprato io ma me l'hanno
regalato perché tutta questa roba da dj
perché mi piace provare a fare il dj per
i cazzi miei non è che vada far serate
però mi piace un sacco io ogni tanto
quando sono quando tempo libero mi metto
lì con la musica la sparo e poi davanti
al muro faccio puccio renza pin di arma
da fucka ed è stato un colpo al cuore
per mio padre perché il mio padre è un
musicista ogni qual volta nel mondo dj
beach stasera io suono un musicista nel
mondo muore non è che sto mandando papa
però io suono questa roba
favi perché non saluti mai nessuno nei
tuoi video molto frequenti sono le
richieste che mi fanno dei miei follower
quando fanno il compleanno e mi chiedono
favi mi fai gli auguri di compleanno
favini saluti che il mio compleanno ci
aspettano compleanno perché io li saluti
non ho capito perché
ma ok calcolatrice alla mano ragazzuoli
miei quanti giorni ci sono in un anno
365 quanti iscritti o io andiamo a
controllare attualmente mentre sto
registrando questo video 3 milioni 250
mila iscritti fa chi è a un quarto di
milione raggiunto grandi grazie speciale
e 250 mila iscritti fra i j sei un ladro
e grandissima facendo 3.250.000 diviso
365 che sono i giorni all'anno troviamo
il numero di persone iscritte al mio
canale che ogni giorno fanno gli anni ed
esce fuori in media circa 9.000 9000 mie
iscritti ogni giorno fanno gli anni in
to see come fa un essere umano a
salutare 9 mila persone al giorno potrei
neanche facendo un video live di 24 ore
dal mattino alla sera non ce la farei a
dire tutti i nomi è impossibile
perdonatemi se non vi saluto se non
posso darvi nei video se non posso
rispondere ciao è perché sennò dovrei
farlo a tutti quanti che uno è più
stronzo dell'altro no tranne quelli ke
mettono i commenti delle gemme quali
sono stronza voi vi saluto e buon
compleanno bastardi fai vedere un tuo
fotografo guardami fare il ladro fallo
bene farlo all'agro farlo bene ruba
questi non le gemme porca lingotti d'oro
devi rubare questi che valgono miliardi
dice prendiamo un foglietto ragazzi nel
lontano ormai 2013 al torino comics al
tempo io incontrai gli oat hobby ciao
karim abbiamo fatto ai tempi una foto e
gli chiesi un autografo perché sono
sempre stato un suo grande fan e lui mi
fece il suo autografo che è all'incirca
questo è un tipo una roba del genere c'è
ed è simile cielo ancora vuoi che parte
forse a torino e tipo una roba del
genere così ecco da quella volta lì ho
detto gag e cacak di autografi e allora
che cosa ho fatto la prima volta che io
ho dovuto fare un autografo qualcuno
l'ho fatto così questo ragazzi e il mio
autografo quindi io non ho la firma per
esteso perché non riesce sono
mongoloide non so perché non so la
riuscita a fanna firma decente quindi
scrivo fa vj stampatello bruttissimo e
poi faccio uno scarabocchio degno di
yotobi e basta questa è la mia firma
quindi il bello che falsificabili sì ma
c'e nel senso uno potrebbe dire a cielo
tra foni famiglia e poi non è mio
assolutamente però io purtroppo c'è non
non hop la scritta fa vj per esteso
perché non mi sono mai messo li enuncia
tempo mancando a pisciare per i video
dove trovare il tempo di fotografie ecco
donald trump quando fai vide incassatura
lancia i lingotti sull'armadio altro che
fai napoli j perché non entri name e
it's funny ma i tuoi genitori guardano i
tuoi video si la risposta è sì
ovviamente non credo che mio padre mia
madre si mettano a guardare tutti i
video che faccio dall'inizio alla fine
poi boh non lo so non credo dio papa non
fare queste cose fatti credo che a mia
madre gli sia avvenuta una sincope
quando tirato il joystick sull'armadio
sicché scusa mamma non volevo non
cliccare sui link di tre suoi alma
marche che sono nelle cagate ti è
piaciuto animali fantastici e dove trova
carlini timer che se domande l'ho visto
due volte al cinema due pali ma anche
casata sei stato smistato ad hogwarts
perché supporter morti smistano con le
casate di harry potter
mi hanno io l'avevo fatto anni fa questo
io sono un tasso rosso non sono da prima
che fosse di moda visto che adesso c'è
news cam under è vero già prima su
camilla minchia l'arcivescovo di
costantinopoli see the asian sporca
[ __ ] [ __ ] se l'arcivescovo di
costantinopoli si dia già this arca
[ __ ] se l'arcivescovo di
costantinopoli see this arcivescovo di
nicchia che sara perche ti fa questa
domanda se l'arcivescovo di
costantinopoli costantinopoli già ci
vestiamo i costantinopoli see this
arcivescovo di napoli tasse tisa giri ma
[ __ ] a se non ti fossi chiamato
lorenzo come avrebbe dovuto chiamarsi i
tuoi genitori questa domanda me l'avete
fatta anche in tal non so perché
interessa sta roba però i miei genitori
mi volevano chiamare claudia anche se
fossi nato maschio fatti di uno scudo
nome claudia mi chiamo club lorenzo
claudia o studi che non mi vorrà
chiamare claudia cioè maschio lorenzo
femmina claudia grazie a dio sono nato
maschio nas scherzando claudia che stai
guardando
subito mi piace il tuo nome mi fa
impazzire quali sono le serie tv che
segue ok la mia preferita in assoluto il
prison break lost e smallville queste
tre sono quelle che sono finito ormai da
tempo che preferite passate diciamo
quelle che è ormai non escono più
puntate quelli invece che sto seguendo
mentre stanno uscendo le puntate sono di
android black mirror che è bellissima è
riuscita ultima stagione ho guardato
anche quello stranger things che ha
dimenticato 20 varie o i met your mother
che vanno nelle serie d prima poi
arriviamo invece a due punti dolenti
anzi tre punti dolenti che sono the
walking dead game of thrones e breaking
bad
perché non li ho seguiti the walking
dead dopo un po di stagioni mi ha
annoiato game of thrones
ho visto le prime cinque puntate la
prima mi è piaciuta da impazzire le
altre è tutt'uno scopare scopare scopare
e per quello ci sono altri siti o almeno
la storia in teoria c'è dietro però non
mi prende per niente quindi va mentre
breaking bad e qui arriviamo al punto
dal tasto più dolente di tutti quanti
dolente perché piacciono non piace alla
gente avanti a tutti piace a tutti
tranne a me ma non è che non mi piace è
bello e le cose brutte sono un'altra
roba
il fatto è che non mi prende non mi
prende breaking bad nel senso che io per
guardare un'altra puntata mi devo
sforzare non ho quella roba che cazzo
devo guardare un'altra puntata subito
che ho con tante altre serie invece non
lo so perché credo sia una questione di
boe di gusti cioè i gusti di merda è
piace la merda ma voi ragazzi vi ho
parlato dei miei cazzi dei mazzi del più
e del meno
potrei continuare dieci giorni a fa
video così ma magari che la finisco che
non interessa un cazzo a nessuno
volevo fare che sta roba da un po nel
senso che era non può che non rispondeva
delle domande quindi ho fatto un megamix
spero che sia a posto se però divide sia
piaciuto ragazzi consenso il momento mi
piace ricordatevi insultare per bene
quelli che si spalmano per me sotto i
miei video che sono delle teste di
minchia sapersi fischiate ricicli
diavolo fosse un video per ragazzi